the most horrifying news story i have
ever seen in my entire life
just popped up on live action
and very few if any establishment media
sources are talking about it because
it's a politically inconvenient crime i
have lived through
many wars all around the world have
taken place in my lifetime all sorts of
terrible crimes murders and and
serial killings and all sorts of things
this is by far
by far the most horrifying crime
uh there
there have been discovered the frozen
remains of five aborted babies in
washington dc and the part of the story
that gets a little weird is they were
found in the apartment of an
anti-abortion activist now it's not
really weird when you figure out what's
going on here a whistleblower at an
abortion clinic tipped off this
anti-abortion activist they have the
evidence of these abortions which are
potentially illegal abortions in that
the babies may have been born or
partially born before they were killed
which would be in violation of federal
law but even if it's not technically in
violation of the civil law
it's obviously it's a crime against
humanity it's a crime that cries out to
god because these are
these are babies these are so undeniably
babies who were who are in in
expressions of extreme pain who are
totally recognizable like any newborn
baby and they were killed through
abortion frankly if it's not in
violation of federal law that's an even
greater indictment of us
uh there are photos of this there's
evidence
i have blurred the photos for this show
because because you'll have nightmares
i would say if you are already pro-life
and you already oppose legal abortion
don't look up these pictures
don't look them up because you'll have
nightmares and there's no reason to you
already see the issue for what it is
if you are pro-choice
if you support legal abortion to any
degree
look up the pictures
click you can find them they're just
google live action abortion washington
dc
you'll see they're kind of blurred out
here
look them up if you if you support
abortion
and you think well it's a complicated
issue i don't like abortion personally
but it should be legal what to whatever
degree you support abortion click the
photos and tell me you support abortion
i don't think anyone but an absolute
stone cold sociopath can look at these
photos
and tell me that they still support
abortion that's why it's so important
the work that live action has done here
so important that the work that this
anti-abortion activist has done here and
the response of the government tells you
everything you need to know about this
evil institution and the
extremely corrupt people who are
covering up for it this anti-abortion
activist
lauren handy i believe her name is
has been indicted so she was the one
she's the anti-abortion activist the
pro-life activist who was discovered to
have these frozen
bodies in her home
that she was apparently given by a
whistleblower
she has been indicted along with eight
others on federal felony conspiracy
charges
what are the charges
she's accused
of blocking access to a dc abortion
clinic in october of 2020.
this blockade
was broadcast on facebook
and now she's up on federal charges
i'm sure she will now have new charges
added to the list
because of her storage of these bodies
do you know who's not going to have any
charges brought against them do you know
who's not going to be held in any way
responsible for these crimes that cry
out to god these the the
the
absolute slaughter of children who have
pained expressions on their face frozen
from this moment do you know who's not
gonna have any consequences the people
who did it that's that's who the person
who blew the whistle on it the people
who expose these crimes to the world
they're probably gonna center behind
bars for a long time the people who
committed these crimes outright
infanticide
nothing is going to happen to them at
all take a listen to the executive
assistant chief of police in washington
d.c
miss handy is been indicted on a federal
investigation led by the fbi that mpd
was not a part of
so that's number one the second piece is
that we were led to that uh house that
you mentioned
uh we did recover items that were
these are preliminary results ocme
looked took a look at those items they
are have been confirmed as fetuses
um
what we're seeing now is they those
fetuses were aborted in accordance with
dc law so we are not investigating
this incident along those lines doesn't
speak anything criminal in nature right
now about that
except for how they got into this house
and so we'll continue to look at that
they were aborted oh no i'm sorry let me
rewind
these items that were found
were fetuses the i so the people the
little babies who were killed they're
they're items they're just objects
and turns out the objects are fetuses
which is the uh the latin word for baby
but we have to use the word fetus so
that we can dehumanize the babies
and the and the babies
were killed they were
killed with these pain expressions on
their faces in accordance with dc law so
there's no crime there nothing's being
investigated
the only crime is how they got to the
house
according to
our authorities i love america
i believe in america to quote the first
line of the godfather
very hard it's very hard to love america
when you hear that kind of stuff
it's very hard
when you think about all the awful
regimes in the world
there are lots of terrible regimes we
we never stop or our ruling class never
stops talking about all the evil regimes
around the world
and then you listen to one of our public
authorities say that the five babies
that we are looking at we can look them
right in their eyes and their cold eyes
we can look at what happened to them and
say there was no crime here
totally in accordance with the law
the only crime
was that this was exposed
if the babies are just items that were
discovered in a home what's the big deal
they just died i have items in my home
you probably have items in your home
don't you we all have items
items not a big deal
it's a big deal and they're
investigating the woman
who had had the bodies in their homes
because their bodies because they're
human beings who were who whose dead
bodies were being treated in this
unusual way
that's why it's a big deal but the the
criminals the killers who killed the
babies they're not being prosecuted or
even investigated because they're not
bodies they're just they're just items
they're trying to have both sides of
this and they're trying to have both
sides to
to attack the good guys to persecute the
good guys who are exposing the crime and
to cover up for the killers
it's very hard i still love my country i
still love america but it's really hard
to do that
when you consider that america kills
upwards of a million babies a year and
speaks of it in such callous terms and
when you see the reality of it when you
can look the babies right in the eye
and these psychos who run our country
say no crime here
they won't perform an autopsy
they can't perform an autopsy because to
perform an autopsy would be to admit
that these are
babies they're not going to perform an
autopsy because by the way
what what the assistant police chief
just said here
very likely isn't true the babies may
very well have been killed in violation
of federal law partial birth abortions
are a violation of federal law and
there's a lot of evidence that that's
how they were killed
but nope cover up nothing to see here
move along move along move along
sick
i'm glad you liked that clip if you want
to get more episodes more clips more
interviews subscribe ring that bell also
head on over to apple podcast spotify
stitcher google play wherever you get
your audio podcast subscribe to the
michael knowles show leave a 5 star
review we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you